it's true our program is packed with
highly interesting sessions and great
speakers and
one of them i would like to introduce to
you it's bobby duffy director
of the policy institute king's college
in london nice to have you with us
bobby your research subject is something
something which is
crucial for democracies and for personal
relationships
it's trust and you are dealing with the
topic of trust between individuals and
trust in institutions
and i'm wondering in the current
pandemic bobby can you
scientifically observe how trust changes
in a crisis like this yeah it's a
great question and you're right that
it's vitally important to
the pandemic response and our day-to-day
lives right now are levels of trust so
it's a really important question
um and we can measure it it's uh it's a
complex issue
trust there are there are issues with
measuring it it's difficult to do it but
the way that we do it is mostly through
structured surveys surveys
representative surveys of the public
where we want to ask people whether they
trust
individuals or the institutions to do
something in particular circumstances
some scholars are skeptical about
whether you what you're actually
measuring
in these simple questions of trust but
when you look at trends over time
in different using different measurement
approaches i think they are measuring
something
meaningful and valuable so yes through
carefully constructed surveys
with rigorous samples i think we can
measure something important about our
levels of trust
i mean it's not the only way in which we
can get an idea of how trusting people
are
it's really important too to look at
people's behaviors and
in particular in these types of crisis
situations how people are acting
as well as what they tell us is really
important to observe
and in general uh bobby do you think
it's more difficult for
people to trust each other
that's a great it's a great question
because we're fed a diet
of endless stories of a new crisis of
trust
um that we're always just in some sort
of crisis state where it's
trust is collapsing in individuals or
institutions
and the truth is when you look at the
long-term trends there have been
some declines in some countries
but it's a very stable pattern or even
rising pattern of trust in
in some institutions in some context so
uh we are probably over exaggerating
this sense of crisis of trust and you
can see that
when you ask questions about people of
do you think
trust is collapsing we're much more
likely to think
trust is collapsing than it actually is
in practice so
uh 64 of people say that
people trust politicians less today
than they did 30 years ago only 10
percent say they trust them
more but when you look at the trends we
were actually just as
untrusting back in 30 years three
decades ago
as we are now so we've got a sense of
change but it's not really changing as
much as people think
you mentioned trust and policy can you
tell us who
are the most trusted and the least
trusted groups in our society
well uh good news from uh from the
situation that we're in now that
actually the most trusted
group in a 22 country study uh that was
done
uh earlier this year is scientists so
60 percent of people across this 22
countries study say they trust
scientists
and then it's doctors next so we've got
this very
strong sense of trust in scientific
information and medical
practice as well teachers come next and
then
at the other end of the spectrum you
have politicians with
in this 22 country study just nine
percent of the public
trusting uh politicians compared with 60
percent for professions like uh
scientists and
and then when you look at institutions
it tends to be the police and judiciary
that come
uh top and at the the other end of the
spectrum on institutions it is things
like political parties
and national government one really
important point though
is it matters hugely which country
you're looking at
so both in terms of level of trust and
the direction that trust is going in so
in norway 62 percent of people
trust their national parliament and
that's only 11
in slovenia it's rising in switzerland
but it's falling in spain and on
scientists barely anyone has low levels
of trust in spain
but over 40 percent of the population in
bosnia
say they have low trust in spain in
scientists so
it is it is a point of being very
specific there's
not one global trend or global measure
of trust it really depends
on which country you're looking at and
which profession
or institution you're looking at so so
what can
science and scientific institutions do
in order
to increa increase their trustworthiness
i think we've got a really good base as
we can see from the trust measures
around the world we are doing pretty
well and then
during the pandemic it trust is held up
in science so there's one 14-country
study that showed
that there's been a rise in trust in
both science and scientists
and a decline in science skepticism
people rejecting
science since the crisis began and
we can see that across all sorts of
different
countries in terms of how do you
improve uh levels of trust it's really
about transparency and communication
being
open and honest with people there's a
there's an interesting stat
stats in the in the uk that the most
visited website
ever in the history of bbc news
websites is people looking for
information about the
the rate of infection in their own area
people are interested in this
and and what the evidence suggests is
more communication
and particularly neutral communication
not aggressive communication with people
open honest transparent with people
we can learn more during the berlin
science week can you tell us
what can we expect from your session
well we will be looking at trust trends
in trust
uh what the future looks like on trust
uh
given that it's so fundamental to uh the
pandemic
uh response um but not just uh
the pandemic response it's really
vitally important to all sorts of big
big challenges that we look at that we
are facing as
a as countries and as the world
things like climate change relies very
much on trust in scientific
information so we need to understand it
better and we are doing
various studies around europe and around
the world on
what determines levels of trust and how
do you improve it in particular
we'll be talking about the underlying
emotional drivers of trust we need to
understand those more carefully how it's
attached to our emotions and our
identity and our values
and we'll discuss that more in our
session today
so we're looking forward thank you so
much bobby duffy from london
thank you for this talk